qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
voyez votre parcours
Richard on va rester dans dans le
monologue on va faire une interview
monologue
qu'est-ce que vous vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
Dieu que je suis moche pendant très
longtemps je me suis pas aimé ah ouais
ouais après j'ai commencé à m'aimer avec
la barbe et là j'ai toujours la couper
pour un film mais et donc je continue à
ne plus m'aimer du tout pour ça vous
êtes pas mal on me l'a dit après oui
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
venez sur un plateau de télé
si je veux vraiment être franche je dis
merde je suis pas à l'aise ah ouais là
ça va vous êtes gentil
avec vous on peut être que gentil
qu'est-ce que je fasse en général je
refuse c'est vrai on voit pas souvent je
crois que c'est même la première fois
que vous venez ici c'était vraiment pour
lui c'est gentil merci pour moi
j'ai dit que je serai franc
mais c'est pas méchant
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous vous
levez le matin
oh je crois que je pense tout de suite à
manger
je me lève avec la fin
c'est bizarre et je me couche avec la
soif d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous vous
regardez dans un miroir ça ressemble un
peu à votre première question
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
seul chez vous le soir devant un miroir
ou pas
de miroir
à vrai dire je suis pas souvent seul le
soir vous pouvez pas être seul j'ai du
mal à être seul
en général je veux qu'une femme quand
même et donc si elle est pas là je sors
on en revient à votre question du début
rien parce que je suis mort de fatigue
et je dors qu'est-ce que vous dites
quand vous voyez votre parcours
des sentiments mélangés
mais comme je suis quand même quelqu'un
de très reconnaissant dans la vie je je
me dis que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
que je suis à privilégié et que
j'aime tellement la vie que j'aimerais
bien la recommencer le double
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
énervé
quand je suis énervé je dis des
j'ai dit des gros mots brésiliens
tes potes
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous avez
envie d'abandonner ce métier
j'ai jamais eu envie de ce métier jamais
jamais le métier me rend jusqu'à la main
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
regardez le journal télévisé mon Dieu
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous ne
recevez pas de scénario
pas de nouvelles bonnes nouvelles
c'est un réflexe de paresseux
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
voyez une actrice qui veut coucher avec
vous
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je lui dis
je dis oui
enfin bon
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez pas confiance en vous
la seule chose que je me dis
c'est c'est un souvenir de mon
grand-père sur son lit de mort qui m'a
dit tu réussiras donc j'ai pas confiance
en moi je me suis souvenu de ça et je
crois qu'il m'a il a porté cette
ultime phrase de son existence m'a
toujours conforté dans et d'un optimisme
caractérisée sur sur mon devenir
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand on vous
dit que vous n'êtes pas drôle
ça m'énerve
mais je reconnais à quiconque de pas me
trouver drôle je ne dirais pas c'est un
con
même si je le pense un peu des fois
mais en tout cas je lui dirai pas
qu'est-ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez rien à vous dire
moi je ferme ma gueule et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu